[Music]
[Applause]
you know who normally doesn't go to the
Super Bowl Dan Le batard Dan Le batard
host of Meadowlark media is the Dan Le
batard show with stugotz and he joins us
now on the program but if I said right
now good morning Dan but if I said right
now
got to make a decision
the Dolphins will be in the Super Bowl
and you're and you're going to take your
show to Las Vegas what would that
decision be
back off this is aggressive
okay all right games in the Dolphins
gonna be in the Super Bowl I'll answer
that before the end of this segment as a
objective journalist and not a fanboy I
will answer that question for you but
I'd like to tell your audience on the
front end at the risk of embarrassing
you a a mentor and an idol and the best
of the Dans in this business
I want you to understand how proud I am
of you that you have cultivated this
audience of family around you and these
people that you work with for a long
time after telling me in the bowels of a
Heat arena that you couldn't do this
that you can only do television and you
couldn't talk for three and four hours a
day I am legitimately proud of the media
Empire you have built and was genuinely
happy when I heard that you were
retiring your way in four and a half
years as someone who left the ESPN
worked in an attic for a while and
crushed it got out of there and just
crushed it so I'm proud of you Dan I'm
sorry if that embarrasses you thank you
Dan I appreciate that now are you taking
your show to the Super Bowl you believe
in the Dolphins
hate the Super Bowl
Super Bowl I don't want to go to the
Super Bowl can you incentivize that I
lose a bet with your show somehow and
then we have to go to the Super Bowl and
I'm gonna do it downtown Dirty Vegas
style because I don't want to do it with
all you corporate suck UPS being out
there uh tied to uh tied to all those
sponsorships and then big guests I'm
going to be off the strip talking to
Carrot Top
how confident are you in the Dolphins
um this is the most overwhelming offense
I have ever seen the franchise play a
franchise of Dan Marino uh two is
getting rid of the ball the way that uh
Tom Brady does in speed with Drew Brees
accuracy and he's got uh four or five
guys on his team that are the fastest in
the league they've been timed to 21-22
miles an hour it's a joy to watch uh the
watch it's a joy what I'm watching uh
and we have time for that I can't say
that about any time I have seen Dolphin
football since Mourinho it's punts it's
16-13 games so what they are is hopeful
and exciting in a way that's gotten
everyone's attention through three games
and I would just remind you a couple of
bounces from being one and two all right
let me bring in Stu gotz because he can
hate on anything
um Stu gotz uh good morning and uh are
you all in on the Dolphins going to the
Super Bowl uh before I get to that Dan I
also want to say how proud I am
I mean who retires four years in advance
announces the retirement doesn't retire
I'm so proud of you thank you
um you know what why don't you guys do
this why don't you announce your
retirement and uh but say it's going to
happen in like five years
oh I'm not going to make it that long
five years okay barely keep the lights
on around here when we're being
interviewed well last last time years
yeah last time the lights went out on
your end
I mean five years were you kidding me
okay company's clearly gonna kill me
okay we were talking about two and a
half key man life insurance two and a
half years do I take the over or under
that what's the bet on getting us to the
Super Bowl come up your team comes up
with some bet that forces us to go to
the Super Bowl because I don't want to
go to the Super Bowl but uh I'm gonna
have to probably if the Dolphins get
there and it I man I can't say that in
my lifetime I've ever had more hope for
a team than what this team in Miami if
they have 13 wins you have to go to the
Super Bowl
if they have 13 wins well what if the
Dolphins aren't in the Super Bowl I mean
well no you have to make the decision
like you got to make the decision oh
you're saying that's the bet 13 wins yes
I am Dan I am scared wait did you just
call me Dave
but you're still proud of me
hey forget it
when my brother died his name is Dave
I'm saying it oh don't do that don't do
that don't play that card
[Laughter]
pocket aces the Dead Brother car I know
but like I'm not playing the dead my
dead dad card did he die too much it
feels like that in my heart
two months ago
your little brother
[Laughter]
he was a great artist
Libo Studio
okay you have a brother named Dave
Patrick I do
yeah yeah
uh but you understand what I'm saying
look I'm an objective Journal are you
still a journalist yeah yeah wow okay
all right
okay so okay Tony Kornheiser respected
newspaper columnist and you know this
from a specific angle because the
newspaper columnists always looked down
at TV Boy Pretty Faces vanity guy
couldn't do it the way the newspaper got
absolutely yes hornheiser who judged you
yes uh he has called himself a yodeler
for a quarter of a century because ESPN
bought all the Watchdogs and turned us
into yodeling cello that would not
criticize the company but am I still a
journalist yes I want for my freedom to
get out of ESPN so that I can say
whatever the hell I want to do about
ESPN that's right all right I am still
out here in these streets fighting next
to a true fool who lies about dying his
beard this morning I did not lie do you
dye your beard let me unintentionally I
don't know Israel he's an intern when I
asked him how his beard got died he said
he didn't do it I don't know how it got
there we'll get to it in a second we'll
get to all your hard questions
but I just want for you to understand
that I am trying in a difficult media
world where we are more politically
divided than ever I am trying to still
be a fair and honest journalist who
cares about the truth impartially
objectively make some mistakes but tries
to cover the teams like a journalist not
like a cheerleader
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh your your entire staff is dancing
behind you
they make me look bad all the time I am
still afraid of Warren Savage won't stop
saying he has bad breath and Warren saps
blaming that on me wow wow
[Music]
uh is the uh Dame Lillard to Miami is
that off the board now again I'm a
journalist of course however I did I
enjoyed this yesterday Dan this was one
of my favorite things that happened
yesterday I got aggregated because I'm I
I'm not a newsbreaker God I hate it's
such a hard job to be the newsbreaker
guy
but I do know what's going on with the
heat I because I know I've been in this
market for 35 years and there are a lot
of people reporting a lot of different
things about what this is bona fides are
you wearing a dolphin cap Dolphin fan
yeah you're a Jets fan I like it yeah
Fins Up yeah I got aggregated yesterday
with this in my mouth because I was
giving dolphin I'm sorry Miami Heat news
and people have called me a not
objective heat mouthpiece and then I'm
you know that I am compromised it's not
woj an Adam schefter who are compromised
because they are shams because they have
so many relationships that they're doing
the bidding of other teams I'm still an
objective journalist but I have true
information on what is happening here
with the Heat and the Portland
Trailblazers and yesterday it got
aggregated while I'm wearing a heat
mouthpiece and Greg Cody is sitting in
shorts on the therapy couch in the
corner without explanation
so I'm going to give you the most
up-to-the-date information that there is
on Dame Lillard to the heat are you
ready I am absolutely ready got Pen in
Hand and I will transcribe this okay I
got to put in the house the mouthpiece
though and I didn't come okay yesterday
okay
so James Lillard wants to be here
and why would he want him here like only
at the very specific Christ that they
have offered Portland there's not a
wrecking horde
Toronto and Milwaukee can have it is
there's leather pieces out there
for somebody who's gonna cost a lot of
money at the end of this contract it
will not overheard
that's coming from an objective
journalist they will not over affect for
game Lily so you'll do whatever you want
to run out and you do whatever you like
you're walking and you idiot Cronin and
Portland you should have gotten a little
a long time ago yeah
we all saw the whole ones are not good
enough to keep them I know I know less
the language
I know less
I know less but you're guaranteeing that
the heat are getting Dame Lillard
The Royals are gonna get James Willard
[Applause]
that's uh Dame Lillard Dan Le batard
Dame lebatard host of the Meadowlark
media is the Dan Le batard show with Stu
guns maybe we'll have a dance off your
Show versus my show let's figure it out
I
want with the consequences of I have to
go to Vegas and suffer Vegas in the
Super Bowl and everything else because
I'd like to see you the the audience
needs to know Dan you really need to
know what an amazing career you have had
I know we'll get we'll get to do the
eulogizing in four and a half years on
what your radio is no because
enough about Dave I mean I mean do you
know how rare this is Dave for you to
have they're only like 10 or 12 people
who get to do this with their own
audience that travels with them and
you're one of them and you did that
after leaving the Beast you did it you
did it the hardest way and you warned me
when I when we left ESPN man it's gonna
be bad for a while I was suffering in my
attic and you are somebody who's got a
very high pain threshold well no you
know fake humility on your part because
you guys have done it as well
um okay but I'm still I remember your
lights stay on I mean well yeah you've
done this done as much better
Furious no I agree with that I mean
people you need not 50. you need four
you got four and they're with you
I got 50. oh crap oh no oh
my God I can't keep the lights on not
again even when the lights are on
nobody's home
thank you Dan that's not true we got a
lot of people downloading us
oh now okay there's no false humility
now we're talking podcast trash
okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
lame trash talk I like that podcast
Trash Talk man
it's like the Sharks and the Jets
um okay guys thank you for joining us if
you're still there and uh yeah of course
you it's the Dan levituck all righty all
righty not sure what we accomplished
there but that's the Dan Le batard show
with stugartz